(beep)
- [Interviewer] Alright Jamal.
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] Where are
you from originally, Jamal?
- Born and raised LA. Killa Cali
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- [Jamal] 48 in actual years,
but 27.
(laughs)
Because prison, you don't age.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you go to prison and
- Yeah, Yeah, Yeah
for all them years?
- Yeah, because if I go
back I'm going to go back
to a maximum security
and I better be ready
Yeah, but...
- [Interviewer] So tell
me about your childhood?
- It's like, I can
remember it was yesterday.
You know, I was I'm the oldest boy of five
My mother, you know what I'm saying?
She, she was a good mother.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause I was the only boy
at one time I can get away with anything.
When I say anything, anything.
So I kept my mother in a lot of trouble.
My mother, she would, she would fight
for me cause I was the only boy.
But one time I got beat up
and came in the house crying.
She told me don't you ever come
in the house crying from getting beat up.
And she told me if you can't beat them up
pick up something and
knock the shit out of them.
It's been effective for 48 years and 27.
For real, I'm very dangerous.
And I'm going to get to that in a minute.
But at the age of nine, something terribly
happened to me.
I didn't know how that
this is going to come,
when this was finna to happen.
And it still affects me today.
More than it did back then.
We was on our way to Louisiana,
my mama and my sister.
When we got to Louisiana.
But, but let me, before
we got to Louisiana,
my mother she was teaching us,
how to go in the ladies
in front of us purse.
when that, cause we didn't have no money.
- [Interviewer] To like steal?
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] Yeah
So I ain't mad at I
would've done the same thing
because I don't know
how we got to that part.
But I knew it was
something because my family
her siblings were scared
or they it's a mystery.
Nobody want to talk about my mother
her own sisters and brothers still today.
But I heard a story, but I
can't believe what they say.
So we stopped at one
Greyhound bus station.
I seen the vending machine
the first vending machine
with all this stuff in it.
It didn't have that
little door that flaps up
and me being a little
I can reach my hand in there and shake it,
Like I'm having a seizure.
And that's how I fed us.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah. I got the name.
My nickname is Poppa
because I watched older people do stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
Well, whatever they do,
I'm watching them that
you know what I'm saying to me?
I still remember it.
So we get there.
And once we get to
Louisiana, where her auntie
my mama auntie stay.
It's like probably one,
two in the morning.
She wouldn't let us in.
Talking about she didn't
have no clothes on.
That didn't make no sense.
We just came all the way to California.
Knowing we don't have no money.
She talking about, come back tomorrow.
Where we gonna go?
Never been homeless at that time before.
So the cab driver was like, okay
y'all can stay with me for night.
I'll take y'all in the morning.
Momma agreed to it, but we
didn't have no other choice.
I was tired because I get a check today.
Cause they said something I'm hyper,
whatever, whatever it is
you know what I'm saying?
But I've been getting
that since the kid anyway.
So when we get to the cab driver,
I instantly go to sleep.
I was the little guy so the bed,
Seemed like I had to climb
off the bed to get off of it.
So somebody is disturbing my sleep.
It's my sister.
Now this is my older sister.
I love her.
That's my that's my -
We witnessed what I'm going
to tell y'all together.
So she wakes me up and
told me to come with her.
We goes in the room, the cab
drivers, trying to have sex
with my mother because
I know what's going on.
I was, I was sharp.
I was sharp.
Cause you know what I'm saying?
I pick up everything where
if my auntie and them,
they say I catch the bus
at five years old with
your order or whatever.
I try to learn something new every day
no matter what it is.
I tried to because yeah, the
my mind is a terrible thing to waste,
it's a terrible thing
to waste the mind to me.
So I'm looking around,
the guy the cab driver.
He has like three shotguns in the corner.
I pick up one of them, cock it.
(laughs)
Right? Cause we-you know, I'm nine so the
pack stuff around my uncles or whatever.
You know see what I'm saying?
Cocked it.
I didn't pull the trigger,
but he knew what was going on.
There was a tied him up.
What? I don't know, all
the stuff that I know.
I don't know where I learned this stuff.
Some of the stuff from,
you know what I'm saying?
I know some more stuff
from, but I prefer not to,
you know cause case could still be open.
So anyway we leave, you
know what I'm saying?
I remember it because I
was fell asleep again.
We went to a hotel, a motel, you know?
Louisiana, I ain't never seen red ants.
And they don't have no sidewalks
and know it was different to me.
So we stayed there for a few days.
We ran out of money.
So now it's a big old trailer trucks,
selling fruits up the
side, we lift up the back
me and my sister would take
cases of all types of fruits.
And today I love all types of fruits.
Yeah. I love it.
So we eventually goes
to my great-grandmother
house where she has money.
You come out there to get some money.
She gots it, she she's
well she's well off.
You know what I'm saying?
And that's the only reason people go out
and own all types of stuff.
So I remember us, we flew back.
So I knew we had some money
and I'm a kid I'm just
programming and stuff.
So we go back, my momma.
We outside and she's reading the Bible.
I remember grandmother
told her bring kids inside,
inside, inside.
you know what I'm saying?
I go to sleep again.
I wake up, I hear my sister jumping
on me, screaming, you know, I see my mama.
She's like right there. You know?
Yeah I don't know what's
going on you know.
No before she laid out,
I see my uncle hit her
but it was like, I was just to drowsy
because I was on psych
meds back then whatever.
I was too drowsy.
So I woke up again and
just remember sister,
saying my mom is dead. My mothers is dead.
I seen him hitting him
with the defibrillator.
I know I knew a lot
but I didn't know what this was going on.
I was like, what's going on?
And they took us outside and what not.
My mother's dead at the age of nine.
They didn't have children's
services like they have today.
Back then nobody came
in to check up on me.
Thank y'all.
Thank y'all
because ...
its sad
that I can't stand nobody
to disrespect my mom
because whatever that, I can't
even put a feeling to it.
But my cousin said when
his mother passed, he said
you've been feeling
this way all that time.
You only get one momma.
So anyway,
next 20, 37 years I'm incarcerated.
Was I a criminal?
Nah, I just was taken care of myself.
I like to fight, you know,
I'm very violent, Mama raised me, mad.
Now ain't now in 2000 what's this? 2000...
They just gave me my check.
I was getting some other weird check.
But now they saying I have PTSD.
I always thought that was
something for a soldier
or what not, what not. I'm like wow,
You know where as I look at my sibling,
I was forced to get therapy
because of the system,
because the law, I don't like the law.
because shorter to my mother's death.
It was cause the police, the sheriff,
choked my uncle in the County jail.
Yeah
His literally, elbow
connected to the thighbone.
Yeah.
Mine is like that.
You know what I'm saying?
Of them doing that to me almost every day,
they didn't kill me.
They didn't killed me,
but they kill him and
But it's a lot of secrets in my family,
that I don't, they don't want to tell.
but it has something to
do with my uncle dying.
You know what I'm saying?
Them killing him.
I remember my grandmother told me,
told the- her daughter
don't call the ambulance
while my momma is over there dying.
I ain't never told nobody
this but she assisted
her daughter from suicide to me.
To me...
because her landlord stayed up front.
As I got a little older,
Imma put it out there.
I ain't got nothing to hide.
One of her siblings
told me and I believe it
that she went over to our house
and she seen my grandmother's
boyfriend coming
out of my momma's room.
That makes a lot of sense.
My mama was very promiscuous
because she had to take care of kids.
Her man is locked away.
I used to go up there for family visits
and I thought that was my
playground and everything
until I really went there as an adult,
then I knew what was really going on.
So anyway, like I said,
I'm very violent cause prison.
Cause I'm a, I'm a gang
member of Westside BPS.
It was my family,
Stone Love is my family.
They took care of me.
I didn't have to go
through training and all.
I was already ready.
So as I looked at my siblings nowadays
my mama had a special batch of kids.
This scar right here.
My sister hit me in the head
18 stables in a coma for four days.
Not knowing I'm being charged
with GTA because I left
work and went away.
So I worked for waste management.
I left work to talk to her
about a problem that I had.
And I don't know what her thinking was
or whatever, whatever, but
I see stars, green clovers
blue diamonds and purple horses.
Lights, camera, action, you're on.
(huffs)
Man, I can't even explain
that but in the process,
now
(slapping)
I can't hear out of it.
how understand why I'm here,
but they shouldn't be there.
They'll make sense.
And all I hear is that, we all hear that
ding sound sometimes it says the governor.
I hear that 24 hours a day.
- [Interviewer] From the hit on the...
- On the hit
- [Interviewer] The
right side of your head,
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] Your right ear broken?
- Yeah, nurse talking to me.
You know what I'm saying?
You used to be louder that
it's going to go away.
That's been almost a year and a half.
Now I have a problem with people thinking,
I'm ignoring them.
People. I can't hear, I can't.
If I drop my phone right
there, I'm going, I can't hear.
And it's frustrating trying to deal
with that with my mental illness
and the substance that I put in my body.
It's not worth it, I know that because
I felt like getting tatted on me
or written isn't, everything's
a lot of stuff that I
did stab my sister in the
eye with a screwdriver
cut her throat, knocked
one of her teeth out,
but I don't remember none of that.
But I see the scar there, like five, six.
I don't remember none of that.
But now that I think about it, I know why
It's called blackout.
My sister stayed behind the hospital,
When she did this.
She came the next day to see me,
wondering how or who's
gonna pay for the window.
Cause I was banging on the window
and it cracked.
She was concerned about this
but it's more to me in my mind.
So as she explained and
starts to apologize,
I instantly forgave her.
Cause nobody knew about the blackout,
when she spoke that she blacked out.
I couldn't hold something small,
over something I'm guilty of doing.
Nobody should get as angry as I get.
I can go from zero to 60 in 0.0 seconds.
Japan, or the military can't disarm me
I played with weapons from a minor.
So prison hey,
here's your acceptance,
taught how to make knives
because prison, it ain't for to help you.
It's only going to corrupt you.
They don't debrief us when they let us go.
I done see you so much.
I done been from Chico to Pelican Bay,
and Creston City.
When I hit there, that's the prison
I was in there 2000.
Look up Jamal Lens.
I wasn't ready for this,
I was but this is it.
This is, Hey, Hey, this is the live show.
Them other level folks, want it .
And and anybody who watch
this, gonna know that.
Yeah, because there ain't no fighting
and stabbing and yeah, it's terrible.
Cause they put all the worst California,
has to offer in one place.
Creston City where rain
eight months a year, I think.
I like to stab people.
I ain't lying.
Look at my record.
My mama played with knives, lady tell me-
She going to get mama get a knife.
That's why, it's nothing personal.
I had to stab my son two years ago
because I ain't never been
disrespected that much,
by nobody people said,
why didn't you fight him?
He didn't deserve a fight
because it is what it is.
I tried diplomacy, when diplomacy fails
then its over.
Family. They say I'm crazy.
I don't know,
My mama had a special batch of kids.
My daughter she's just like me.
I been gone all them years.
How can she have my addict attitude.
She already got two strikes
and she ain't even 22.
And she was born my mommas birthday.
That's why you see these two names,
with the libra sign there.
All the days in the world.
Why? On my momma's birthday.
- [Interviewer] October 17
- Yeah, and she been gone...
Damn near 30 years. Hmm mm
Its a lot of stuff I
just don't understand.
But maybe it aint up to me to understand.
Cause when I was a kid,
I was told that white guy
with that perm with the blue eyes,
that was Jesus.
Right?
Okay.
Because they was taught
that, they was taught that
they was taught that,
they was taught that.
But when I started doing time in prison
I call it the hidden university
because you learn a lot, a lot.
I forgot.
My sister told me one day,
she's like when is this going to stop?
you be in there every morning,
more than you be out here.
I do the time, time don't do me.
I don't count the years.
And I'm doing it years gone.
I come from a very, very good family.
How we started before
they started passing away.
I love you auntie Lynette.
Cause she kept us together.
And my sisters and them know that
there wasn't no, I don't
get along with you.
At every Saturday or
some we doing something.
Not just because of my mother's death
but she had it like that.
And she was about family.
Every year on my mommas birthday,
she take the whole family,
everybody to Disneyland.
She had it like this.
She was in the army.
You know
Well,
but
you know...
Once she got,
they didn't even tell
me I was incarcerated.
When she passed they didn't even tell me.
(sighs)
Probably would have killed me.
Cause I played with suicide before
I'm just a coward to do it,
anything else I'll do it.
Cause I ain't ready to go.
I still got stuff to do.
- [Interviewer] The first
time you were in prison
(police sirens)
was at what age?
- [Jamal] Woo, about eleven.
(police sirens)
Eleven years old, Robbery.
- [Interviewer] And how
long were you in prison for?
(police sirens)
- [Jamal] That wasn't like prison,
like juvenile hall.
Well there's junior prison, cause its
stages to go through that shit.
You see people go through boys home,
foster homes. But I went from boys home,
Y which is junior prison,
where you really learn how to fight.
As soon as you come through
the door, where are you from?
I'm from this.
Fuck this.
And y'all fight.
So that's the- then us being the minority,
because for everyone one blood
is probably twenty crips.
We held our shit.
It's hard to be a blood.
We paved the way for y'all now.
But a lot of you bloods just say bloods
y'all aint bloods.
And I can tell, cause I'm gonna look
on the back of your neck,
and I know what he's going to say.
It's going to say made in China.
But, I ended up going to juvenile hall.
I was very violent man.
But I was in a foster home.
Mom was, she was unstable.
A lot of times.
A lot of times she running from family.
It's stuff I can't answer,
but stuff me and my sister remember,
who that, Oh, we would've stayed there
and what not cause if
foster home would of win,
the people tried to keep me.
But I don't know.
I didn't know how it
worked then or whatnot.
When my mama finally got
his back and I just thought
about that.
Did she get us back to take her life?
It was a lot going on
my mama was depressed.
And I looked at all my
siblings, all of them got issues
and I can diagnose them.
They don't want blessing.
Hey, get some therapy because
some third, cause then
I was molested at the age of
probably let me see eleven
Yeah around that time because you-
faggot motherfucker.
I was eleven years old I
already had issues man.
Dumb motherfucker you could
have changed my sexuality.
Lucky. I'm a lesbian only mess with women.
- [Interviewer] Who's this?
- My friend's father, sick son of a bitch.
But,
I believe
my auntie allowed it to happen
every time.
I believe,
her son believe
because this faggot
motherfucker had two 11
10 year old sucking their
dicks at the same time.
He had too much time,
But that's when they
had the cocaine that was
called a Peruvian flake.
My auntie and probably
was high off the plate.
Cause it's like, no kids is.
There's something about kids sleep.
When you got to go to school
that'd be the best sleep in the world.
It aint time for me to get up.
But I got to piss.
Cause at that age I wasn't nothing.
So Ill wake up know I'm saying
(heavy breathing)
Slide a 50 dollar bill in my hand,
Real shit.
His son told me, my daddy said, yeah
let your dick ride to the left,
it make it look big.
Huh?
Shit
He sucking on both of them same
He buying us shoes and stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
Not that he's doing bad, but
50 dollars for a 11 year old kid,
and you young
because all the schools I went through
I ain't gonna say I was special ed
but I was special ed
cause I was the class clown.
I fucked, that's the worst thing you
motherfuckers should of never did
was fuck me.
Cause now y'all turned me into a bully.
I'm bigger than everybody in this school,
Whoever the kid in school,
I'm coming for that pussy nigga,
to whoop your ass.
I had some nice girlfriend.
And I'm sorry for the
mothers that your daughters
when they were eleven
and twelve, I was fucking
they were too.
Because I knew more than they knew.
You could have changed my sexuality.
I think it affected me
because I don't really care
about oral for oral sex.
As you can see, I got a tattoo of a man,
Giving a bitch pleasure.
I love eating pussy,
and I'm like the energizer
bunny when I'm in that
pussy still going.
Cause I love her-
I think I'm gonna be a porn star.
I'm a comedian too son.
But this story that I'm saying is true.
Again, I ran into a girl.
Oh.
Yeah, God be like you going to hell
Hold on, let me get me
some head one more time.
Then you can send me to hell.
Boy
But,
and I'm the king of the bare backs.
That means a lot of times,
I ain't put no socks on a pickle.
I am so fortunate
for real
but my sexual demon is, you know,
they call it tricking.
I call it paying for what I want.
Because now I believe a woman,
can stand on any corner,
and sell her pussy and make money.
So I'm selling this dick by the pound.
I can't do it that way.
If I stay on the corner,
only one that's gon' pick me up
He going to be gay.
And that's the price you have to pay.
We have to see it all the time.
Worked for a...
A gay person.
Everybody else stereotype.
All of us that worked there.
Girl said I thought you was gay?
I am I'm lesbian, I only mess with women.
I asked my sister last week, was she mad?
I ain't even giving a fuck.
And I said that if she
cared, I said, she cared
if I be a porn star because I love it.
I been go out, you know
they recommend that
I go to a sex- What it is?
A sex, sex class, sex, sex addiction.
Now all the women there,
that listen to this story.
I got my phone book listed.
Why? That don't help.
I got to go back though,
because I enjoy it.
You know what I'm saying?
And I aint have to pay for it,
but
I want to be happy.
I ain't trying to live the American dream.
Remember that?
Ain't my dream.
I just want to be happy
because I have so much hurt and pain.
You know, that's why I get so emotional.
And when people get it fucked up
you see tears out these eyes.
That don't mean I'm a softie.
That mean you better run and hide.
I am you know, y'all aint gonna kill me.
I'm a survivor.
And I don't work for United States Army.
I don't.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.
- No problem.
Thank you for listening.